hola
[Música]
colombia se prepara para una transición
de gobierno el próximo 7 de agosto un
cambio de mando que implica un giro en
la política del país hay mucha
expectativa sobre lo que vendrá para
colombia en materia social económica y
política pero sobre todo en materia de
paz a lo largo de los cuatro años de
gobierno eduque al mandatario lo
señalaron de ser muy selectivo en los
puntos de la implementación del acuerdo
de paz una implementación también
criticada por ser muy lenta pero en
realidad fue así vamos a ver algunos
puntos básicos del balance que se puede
hacer de algunos puntos destacados de la
gestión del presidente eduque según el
último reporte de la fundación ideas
para la paz después de cuatro años de
gobierno del presidente eduqué la
implementación y la paz presentan el
siguiente escenario hay un
fortalecimiento de los grupos armados al
margen de la ley hubo también un aumento
del 7 por ciento en la tasa de
homicidios un aumento del 105 por ciento
en el número de masacres a nivel
nacional unos 930 líderes sociales
fueron asesinados de ellos 114 solamente
en el primer semestre del 2022 la
mayoría de esas víctimas han sido
eres han sido indígenas
afrodescendientes e integrantes de la
comunidad lgtb del q según el último
informe que presentó la defensoría del
pueblo entidad que hace seguimiento
precisamente a la implementación del
acuerdo de paz el gobierno de duke
entregó unos mil 442 predios a favor de
seis mil 384 familias cerca de un millón
novecientos doce mil
839 hectáreas fueron incluidas en el
fondo de tierras lo que se traduce en un
avance del 62 por ciento para llegar a
esa meta de 3 millones de hectáreas del
total de las familias inscritas en el
programa nacional de sustitución de uso
ilícito un 92 por ciento han recibido ya
pagos de asistencia alimentaria por
parte del gobierno un 91 por ciento han
recibido asistencia técnica integral y
un 82 por ciento han sido beneficiados
con proyectos de seguridad alimentaria
también un 55 por ciento han sido
beneficiados con proyectos de productos
de ciclo corto
ese después a muy groso modo algo del
balance que se puede decir de lo que
avanza colombia en cuanto a la
implementación de paz por parte del
presidente iván duque en temas
relacionados con este acuerdo que sigue
generando muchas divisiones en el país
pero el presidente electo gustavo petro
ha reiterado ser un defensor de este
acuerdo y ha propuesto junto a su
fórmula vicepresidencial francia márquez
25 puntos para buscar la paz en el país
destacar a algunos de ellos no todos
porque la lista es larga pero petro da
un completo apoyo a ese acuerdo firmado
por el gobierno colombiano y la entonces
guerrilla de las farc como lo decía
propone 25 puntos para reforzar o
también para agilizar lo pactado entre
ellas por ejemplo la negociación con
grupos armados al margen de la ley como
por ejemplo el clan del golfo o la
guerrilla del l en una reparación de las
víctimas que ha sido bastante lenta en
la actual implementación una reforma
rural para ser más productiva a la
tierra y en cuanto a la lucha contra las
drogas no piden no estigmatizar a
quienes se ven obligados a sembrar coca
y también propone abordar el consumo de
drogas como un problema de salud pública
sólo por mencionar algunos todo esto se
ve muy bien en las propuestas ya veremos
más adelante en detalle a lo largo del
programa qué tan factible es poder
llevar a cabo este tipo de propuestas
que hace el presidente electo de los
colombianos entonces a pocos días de esa
transición de gobierno y siendo la paz
un tema que genera tanta controversia y
división al interior de colombia qué
futuro le espera podrá ser implementado
por fin ese acuerdo de paz en totalidad
perdió el todavía presidente iván duque
una oportunidad de haber escrito una
página muy diferente en la historia del
país alejado de las críticas de los
desfalcos precisamente de fondos para la
paz y de los señalamientos por mantener
un discurso partidista la difícil lucha
de colombia por alcanzar la paz es
nuestro tema de hoy en el debate de
france 24 y para analizar y para
conversar sobre este tema hemos invitado
a daniel a garzón ella es politóloga e
investigadora de la fundación paz y
reconciliación nos acompaña en el
estudio de france 24 y desde la ciudad
de chía en los suburbios de bogotá se
conecta a rodrigo pombo él es abogado
defensor de derechos humanos les
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación pueden dejar todas
sus preguntas y comentarios a través de
las redes sociales
estamos en twitter estamos en instagram
también estamos en facebook en donde no
se encuentran como france24 bajo ese
arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta ese numeral el
debate efe 24 en youtube también pueden
seguir nuestra señal en streaming y
aprovecho para saludar a las personas
que están escuchando nuestro podcast los
invito para que escuchen todos los
contenidos de nuestro programa que ya
están disponibles en app el podcast en
spotify deezer y tuning
pues muy bien le doy la bienvenida
entonces a danielle aquí en el estudio
de france24 daniela gracias por
acompañarnos hoy en el programa punto de
partida como me gusta llamar a la
primera pregunta del programa para
conocer opiniones de los invitados y
desde su balance en líneas generales
antes de profundizar que deja el
presidente de duke en materia de paz y
que recibirá entonces el presidente
electo gustavo petro que tanto margen
tendrá para añorar la paz del presidente
pero bueno yo creo que eduque sin duda
pues no iba a ser el presidente de la
paz porque su partido el centro
democrático fue el principal opositor a
el acuerdo que se firmó en 2016 de hecho
fue el líder del no en el plebiscito
entonces era esperable pues que la
bandera de la paz no fuera primordial
para el bando que creo que es lo que
vemos y lo que vemos por ejemplo en
materia de seguridad y de derechos
humanos en colombia en este momento lo
que acabas tú de mostrar un aumento
inusitado de las masacres de la muerte
de líderes sociales no se presentaron
pero también muchas muertes de ex
combatientes que habían firmado el
acuerdo de paz y estaban en medio su
proceso de reincorporación y creo que
pues gustavo petro recibe un balance
desalentador pero el principal problema
que tiene es que la paz ya salió un poco
del discurso de la agenda pública de
hecho a pesar que lo incluye en su
programa de gobierno no creo que haya
sido un punto fundamental por el cual
logró elegirse y ese va a ser un reto
porque si bien para gustavo petro por
ejemplo temas como la reforma agraria y
cómo combatir la violencia y de hecho
pues plantear unos diálogos de entrada
con el ine van a ser importantes y esta
idea de la paz total pues hay que ver
qué tanto margen de maniobra tiene con
otros problemas como el del empleo como
el de la inflación que claramente están
mucho más presentes hoy en la agenda
pública claro y son temas que tal vez en
este momento por la coyuntura le importa
un poco más a la ciudadanía antes que la
implementación del acuerdo de paz la
vila bienvenida también a rodrigo en la
ciudad de chía rodrigo gracias por
acompañarnos en el programa y la misma
pregunta como punto de partida que deja
el presidente eduque entonces en materia
de paz de la implementación que recibe
gustavo petro y que tanto futuro tiene
la implementación de ese acuerdo
la respuesta tendría que partir sobre
una digamos relativa y
consensual y zación sobre qué es paz
porque recordemos que en el pacto del
doctor santos con las farc con las
otroras farc pues se manejaron cuatro
distintas concepciones de paz paz como
ausencia de conflicto paz como
reinserción de las farc a la vida civil
y política paz como desarrollo integral
inclusive se habló de un crecimiento
sostenido del 1.9 por ciento del
producto interno bruto y paz simplemente
como abolición de cualquier
manifestación violenta lo que incluye la
negociación con cualquier grupo armado
organizado por fuera de la ley es decir
un grupo criminal entonces dependiendo
de lo que se entienda por paz podemos
decir que al presidente de duke le fue
más o menos bien de acuerdo a los
indicadores objetivos que muestran las
cifras como una de ellas que usted acabo
de mostrar suficientemente bien dadas
por la defensoría del pueblo y no por el
gobierno nacional no por el oficialismo
y el discurso oficialista sino por la
defensoría del pueblo eso como punto de
partida pero digamos que de entrada uno
diría que lo que se alcanzó con el
acuerdo del gobierno a santos con las
farc pues tenía tantas falencias ya no
digo solo de legitimidad popular
manifestado entre otras cosas el 2 de
octubre del 2016 en las urnas sino que
tiene unas falencias conceptuales muy
grandes
una de ellas que creo que viene al punto
en el programa de hoy tiene que ver
precisamente con el concepto de paz
total manejada por la nueva
administración del presidente petro
petro ha dicho una cosa que me parece
elemental pero no por eso menos
importante o la paz es total o no hay
paz y lo cierto es que en colombia
seguimos inmersos en una guerra desde
1930 con distintas modalidades
entonces llevamos 90 años de una
franquicia guerra interior que
evidentemente necesita puntos creativos
y los 25 puntos presentados por el nuevo
gobierno el gobierno del doctor gustavo
petro a mi modo de ver son absolutamente
lo mismo de lo mismo cero creatividad
cero espontaneidad cero
digamos puntos que vislumbre en un
horizonte distinto a lo que los
colombianos venimos acostumbrados en las
últimas tres o cuatro décadas de tal
manera que si es coincidiría con la
doctora daniela la diferente perdón la
posibilidad de que el doctor petro pueda
lograr poner la paz total como uno de
los puntos centrales de su gestión va a
ser muy difícil porque la gente ahora
indica lo que necesita es básicamente
llevar el pan a la mesa del empleo
formal y de calidad es decir asuntos más
de subsistencia soy el ente eléctrico de
política general bueno quiero utilizar
esta primera parte del programa para
analizar y hacer balance de lo que deja
entonces el gobierno eduque en
profundidad lo hemos visto ya en la
introducción del programa algunas de las
cifras unas positivas unos aspectos
negativos también
profundicemos allí para explicarle a la
audiencia más allá de las fronteras
colombianas cómo está situación de el
avance del acuerdo y porque desde tantos
sectores lo critican al presidente por
no haber implementado el acuerdo y por
haberse quedado con el discurso del
partido y no haber aprovechado tal vez
esa oportunidad a nivel político para el
haber elaborado o haber desarrollado
este plan de trabajo que había con el
acuerdo de paz que tal vez le hubiera
podido generar un poco más de prestigio
a nivel internacional y no tantas
críticas daniela bueno yo creo que en
primer lugar y por ejemplo si uno revisa
el balance que presenta el instituto
creo que es formalmente en la entidad
encargada de hacerle un balance a cómo
estará la implementación del acuerdo de
paz lo que uno encuentra es que si hay
varios digamos ha habido un avance en
iniciar más o menos 578 puntos que
habían quedado y que ellos toman como
punto de referencia para mirar qué tanto
se ha implementado la paz pero el grueso
de los puntos de los seis puntos que se
habían acordado quedaron en mínimo o
están en intermedio punto de
implementación lo cual ya debería ser
alarmante por otro lado creo que había
avances significativos en temas por
ejemplo como el tenis y la sustitución
de cultivos
un problema fundamental que ha sido el
problema del narcotráfico que colombia
aún no le encuentra ninguna salida y
muchos hablan de la legalización sin
tener en cuenta que eso no es una salida
viable en términos de que colombia no
puede ir a convencer a los demás países
que tienen bloqueada esa legalización
entonces tiene que buscar otras
soluciones hacia adentro y pues
finalmente ese programa prácticamente
quedó es financiado y no salió adelante
a pesar de que por ejemplo las tasas de
resiembra eran muy bajas y estaba
habiendo como una muestra clara que el
programa estaba funcionando por supuesto
en temas de reforma
rural el avance es mínimo y más ahora
cuando vemos por ejemplo que la
priorización que había en municipios
puede pues termina esto en una una
piñata de los políticos tradicionales
más algunos funcionarios de entidades
tan importantes como el como el
departamento nacional de planeación y
creo que además duque gasto buena parte
de su capital político en temas como las
objeciones a la gente que finalmente no
pasaron que terminaron entorpeciendo
también un poco la labor de la justicia
especial de paz y dando mensajes muy
negativos a ni siquiera ir por ejemplo a
recibir el informe de la comisión de la
verdad esté de acuerdo o no con él lo
con lo que dice el informe porque es un
manda una una clara señal de que él no
les apostando realmente a la
implementación del acuerdo de paz y por
ende tenemos estos resultados por
ejemplo bastante os estamos contando que
en términos de vidas y cómo lo decía
rodríguez y un hablar de una ausencia
del conflicto pues en este momento lo
que estamos viendo es un fracaso porque
estamos nuevamente viendo un aumento en
las tasas de violencia muy preocupantes
aunque yo no estaría de acuerdo con
rodrigo en que estamos en la misma
guerra porque creo que por ejemplo haber
sacado de la guerrilla más potente que
tenía incluso américa latina y que tenía
un discurso político del monte font fue
el principal logro del acuerdo de paz y
ni siquiera duque que no le puso mucho
empeño logró echarlo para atrás creo que
por eso habría que hacer un empeño aún
mayor en ver cómo se negocia con él ln y
después ver que esa guerra que nos queda
o ese conflicto armado que nos queda
pues ya no tiene necesariamente que ver
con razones políticas y ahí hay unos
márgenes en los que el estado puede
actuar de manera diferente
buen punto daniela rodrigo le doy la
palabra si quiere refutar alguna cosa de
lo que ha dicho daniel y también su
punto de vista sobre este esta pregunta
que he hecho y sobre lo que representa
le extiendo un poco la pregunta sobre
las consecuencias que esto le va a dejar
a colombia el haber hecho esta lenta
implementación del acuerdo haberse
distanciado de lo pactado eso no
generaba más división no
dañaba esas bases del acuerdo de paz y
no jugaba tal vez con poco beneficio
para la ciudadanía
colombiana sí
en haber desconocido el resultado del 2
de octubre del 2016 a mi modo de ver y
ya mirándolo además con cierta
perspectiva histórica santiago llevó a
que uno pudiera afirmar hoy en día con
total
asertividad que la nación colombiana
quedó dividida en dos y a mi juicio creo
que y
reinvente dividida de tal manera que
cualquier aviso de legitimidad que se le
puede dar a cualquier política pública
de orden público o de paso como usted
quiera denominar va a ser bastante
difícil por no decir imposible pero
además de eso yo lo que sí creo es que
en un momento dado la humanidad entera
tuvo que tomar una suerte de
priorización en la política pública y
todo esto por cuenta de una cosa
evidente que a nadie se le puede escapar
y es el kobe 2019 o la pandemia
universal
y me parece que lo que decidió el
gobierno colombiano del presidente educa
con una cantidad de falencias que yo soy
el primero en recordarlas
pues fue acertado fue decir vamos a
aplicar un acuerdo de financiado que
según fedesarrollo en solo de los cinco
puntos el primero sobre acuerdo integral
de tierras o reforma integral agraria y
el punto cuatro sobre el tema de
cultivos y listos valen 140 billones de
pesos algo así como 14 reformas
tributarias y para el plazo de ejecución
algo así como dos reformas tributarias
por año lo cual es obviamente imposible
de cumplir o dedicarse a evitar la
hambruna que produciría la pandemia y
creo que el haber subsidiado a 21 9
millones de compatriotas en una nación
que tiene 50 aproximadamente un poco
menos 50 millones de habitantes fue el
paso correcto fue el camino correcto
había que darles subsidios primero a los
trabajadores a la nómina que la gente no
se muriera de hambre y no perdiera su
trabajo segundo al adulto mayor y
tercero a los jóvenes 29 millones de
compatriotas durante 2 años recibieron
subsidios ultra venosos directos para no
morirse de hambre y creo que eso fue lo
correcto creo que eso evitó que colombia
entrara en un nivel de destrucción del
tejido social en el tejido productivo
que llevase a una miseria que generación
una tierra fértil para que a su turno se
hablara de legitimar cualquier
levantamiento armado por cualquiera de
estos grupos armados organizados pues me
pareció que en ese sentido el gobierno
lo que hizo lo mejor que cualquier
gobierno del mundo hubiera podido haber
hecho eso lo dice la ocde eso lo dicen
los estándares internacionales eso lo
dice el fondo monetario internacional y
el banco mundial
ahí hay unos resultados que no se pueden
desconocer desde nuevo aquí lo cosa el
problema santiago la disyuntiva era
atender la hambruna o atender un acuerdo
entre el gobierno del doctor santos y
las farc bastante ilegítimo por cuenta
de una elección que perdiera el rodrigo
continuó con usted para hacer la ronda a
la inversa ya le doy la palabra daniela
el presidente duque abogó por la defensa
de la paz son palabras que él dijo en
varias intervenciones en que defendía la
paz pero sin que ello supusiera el
sometimiento del estado a los
delincuentes fue un discurso que no
solamente dio en colombia sino que
también fue parte de sus comentarios a
nivel internacional precisamente
buscando fondos para la paz se le
criticó mucho que internacionalmente si
era un defensor del acuerdo y en este
proceso de paz pero a nivel local no se
mostraba tan de acuerdo pero que tanto
margen de maniobra tenía el estado
colombiano a la hora de negociar porque
no sé si ustedes tienen la misma
impresión pero el gobierno colombiano o
el estado colombiano no ganó la guerra
entonces qué tanto optan al margen
colombiano para presionar en ese acuerdo
finalmente era una negociación y a ambos
les tocaba acceder no sé si tienen la
misma perspectiva rodrigo
con comparto filosóficamente
conceptualmente el punto de partida un
estado de derecho un estado social de
derecho pierde cuando no gana es decir
pierde cuando no logra establecer las
condiciones mínimas de convivencia
pacífica por eso se reserva el monopolio
legítimo del uso de las armas por eso se
reserva la expedición monopólica de la
moneda por eso se reserva la expedición
monopólica de las reglas de juego
llamadas leyes y esos monopolios tienen
como único propósito ulterior propósito
el de mantener la armonía social es
decir la paz la armonía entre las partes
como dirían santo tomás y los
escolásticos y yo creo que esa paz con
legalidad es decir la aplicación
irrestricta del estado social de derecho
era lo correcto es el imperativo que la
constitución política de
1991 ordena y era lo que había que hacer
claro hay una posición en moral política
y económica muy respetable que dice que
lo que debe hacer cualquier estado en
estas circunstancias es adelantar una
cultura del diálogo por los criminal y
llegar a unos niveles a los que hemos
llegado con las farc de tal manera que
se sentó el precedente de que si con las
farc se logró este tipo de negociación
310 páginas se le hacen parte del bloque
de constitucionalidad que demanda más de
140 millones de pesos en su
implementación y que además le permite a
los ex terroristas pues liderar los
destinos de este país en el congreso de
la república y en otra serie de actos de
cargos públicos pues naturalmente esa es
una visión que no compartía más de la
mitad de el país hace cuatro años hoy
siente hoy el país está juzgado con esa
visión respetable ese es el juego
democrático claro daniela por este lado
que tanto margen de acción habilidad que
tanto podría exigir el gobierno y
claramente yo creo que cuando uno
negocia significa él está digamos el
fracaso del estado en términos militares
y creo que ese es el estado de cosas
tanto con las farc como por ejemplo hay
hoy con el ln y con otros grupos o sea
partamos de la base de que
independientemente de si les gustaba o
no el acuerdo lo cierto es que en
materia de seguridad hay un problema
mayor que teníamos hace cuatro años y
eso les da unas condiciones de
exigibilidad
armados así le parezcan reprochables que
por supuesto son reprochables todas las
actuaciones de sus grupos pero el estado
invitar mente no ha sido capaz de
vencerlos por eso les tocó hacer unas
concesiones y ahí y por eso tocó que
haya unas curules de las farc y que
ellos tengan una representación política
porque les reconocemos además un estatus
político primera cosa segunda cosa yo
creo que si un estado firmó un acuerdo
así el siguiente gobierno no le parezca
debería cumplirlo porque también se mina
la legitimidad del estado cuando tú
firmas y no cumples porque cuál es la
garantía que tienen los siguientes
incluso los ciudadanos normales que no
cargan fusibles de que el estado les va
a cumplir sí y también yo creo que hay
un tema acá de uno puede discutir que
tan legítimo no legítimo ser acuerdo de
paz con las farc pero yo creo que
moralmente colombia tenía la obligación
de buscar la manera de parar el desangre
y eso fue lo que hizo juan manuel
santos- pasarte que a mi juicio fue una
torpeza a votar el plebiscito por lo que
ya señaló rodrigo pero era un imperativo
moral parar el desangre porque es que si
vemos únicamente los últimos 20 años de
conflicto que fueron los más graves
según todas las cifras de contradictores
o de personas incluso a favor del
gobierno uribe pues lo que uno ve por
ejemplo políticas como los como las
ejecuciones extrajudiciales que incluso
en los últimos días hemos visto cosas
dramáticas en la jurisdicción especial
de paz nos muestran hasta donde nos
llevaron por ejemplo la búsqueda una
salida militar y es que murieran
muchísimos más civiles que personas en
combate tanto de los del ejército
colombiano como de las guerrillas
entonces creo que era un imperativo
moral hacerlo y fue lo que juan manuel
santos hizo y era una obligación en
parte de iván duque si no le gustaba
este plan al menos diseñar otro pero ni
se diseñó otra y se cumplió este y en
este momento tenemos este estado de
seguridad muy complejo que además se
suma a lo que ya dijo rodrigo y es que
tuvimos una pandemia de por medio que
agravó mucho las condiciones económicas
que se están viviendo en colombia lo
cual probablemente va a ser un incentivo
para la criminalidad porque realmente
pues a pesar de que las transferencias
condiciones no condicionadas lograron un
poco como ser un colchón del golpe lo
cierto es que hoy económicamente el
mundo está muy mal y colombia tiene un
margen de maniobra muy pequeño porque no
es un país que sea relevante en el
escenario internacional y entonces creo
que hay es en ese punto en el que recibe
gustado petro este estado de cosas y no
sé si ustedes están de acuerdo pero creo
que vuelve y deja en evidencia la
pandemia de kobe y 19 un grave problema
estructural del estado colombiano y es
la presencia en las regiones quedó aún
más en evidencia que el estado no podía
llegar a todos los sitios hacer
presencia atenderá a estas comunidades
alejadas precisamente para darles
asistencia en la parte médica para hacer
frente con las vacunas o la asistencia
que necesitarán y eso también le dio más
paso a los grupos delincuenciales
daniela continuó con usted pregunta
corta para ir pasando ya al tema petro
ya lo que viene para la paz y cerrando
el balance del gobierno eduque se
perdieron estos cuatro años se
retrasó mucho la implementación esto que
costó va a tener para la paz colombiana
es muy difícil establecer el
contrafactual y saber qué hubiera pasado
si hubiera habido otro ritmo de
implementación pero lo cierto es que por
ejemplo en temas rurales sigue habiendo
un problema un conflicto sobre la tierra
que colombiano ha resuelto y que es
fundamental porque los sobre la tierra a
mi juicio siguen siendo la carne y el
cultivo de los grupos armados ilegales
en colombia que estamos hablando del
narcotráfico minería ilegal también
pasos de trochas por ejemplo y lugares
donde el estado no ha podido establecer
una soberanía plena como son el bajo
cauca donde viene el clan del golfo el
pacífico nariñense y el cauca donde hay
un conflicto sobre la tierra que incluye
un problema étnico que tampoco está
resuelto y fundamentalmente el catatumbo
donde hace muy poco vimos patrullando a
la ln a sólo 8 minutos de donde queda el
batallón militar entonces sin duda no
creo que se perdió nuevamente hay un
tema sobre cuál es la soberanía que
tiene el estado colombiano sobre el
territorio y segundo creo que siguen sin
resolver problemas como el narcotráfico
para el cual el acuerdo con las farc
planteaba una ruta y no se siguió y la
ruta que siguió este gobierno fue la
ruta tradicional de intentar volver a
esperar que está prohibido pues digamos
que está suspendido por el consejo
estado desde el 2015 que colombia es uno
de los pocos países que todavía está
esperando con glifosato la erradicación
no ha funcionado porque lo que vemos es
una disminución mínima de los cultivos
ilícitos o incluso una los cultivos en
estos años y en las otras materias pues
hay asuntos pendientes particularmente
el tema de la seguridad de los
excombatientes debería ser un punto
fundamental y también pues la presencia
de otros grupos como las dos disidencias
una pues que salió precisamente desde
algunos ex park que es la segunda
marquetalia y lo que ha pasado con la
línea de gente duarte y por supuesto la
lln que encontró en venezuela un caldo
de cultivo en parte porque este gobierno
a pesar de todas las disparidades que
tenía con el gobierno de nicolás maduro
fue incapaz de establecer una ruta
diplomática para que no se convirtiera
esa frontera en un campo pues de cultivo
para los grupos armados que hay operan
hoy llegando ya un poco más allá de la
mitad del programa paso entonces a lo
que viene para colombia
sé que se me quedan por fuera muchos
puntos para analizar del caso del
presidente eduque y la implementación
pero debo avanzar con otros puntos y lo
estábamos leyendo algunos de estos 25
puntos que propone el petró para la
implementación de esta paz
total es muy ambicioso rodrigo este plan
y todo suena muy lindo en las palabras
todo suena muy lindo en el papel pero
qué tan factible es poder
estos 25 puntos ya usted nos dijo que le
parecía poco creativo
pero no sólo porque me parezca y en
efecto es poco creativo sino que en la
práctica y le respondo su pregunta con
el mismo contenido de la pregunta es que
sus 25 puntos doctor santiago no sólo no
contemplan nada nuevo sino que ya se han
venido trabajando con relativa
intensidad en unos periodos
presidenciales con mayor intensidad en
otros con menor intensidad pero ya
colombianos ha intentado el único quizás
que genera una duda en tanto que si es
un enfoque constitucional en materia del
manejo de orden público absolutamente
novedoso es la
descentralización de el orden público es
decir los acuerdos o los pactos
regionales de paz eso no se ha explicado
suficientemente bien eso puede ser muy
exitoso o un fracaso estrepitoso vamos a
ver en qué termina pero lo que sí es
cierto es que estos 25 puntos ya se han
venido tratando en el pasado y yo diría
que pues a juzgar por la realidad actual
para casarnos como sociedad y las
guerras irregulares
no desde el punto de vista militar se
pierden desde el punto de vista político
y esas políticas que está trayendo el
nuevo gobierno ya fracasado en el pasado
y me parece que por la gente que están
poniendo en el alto gobierno por quienes
están liderando moral y
administrativamente esos 25 puntos pues
tendríamos toda la autoridad moral para
decir que van a volver a ser un
auténtico fracaso y van a ser un fracaso
porque se requiere mucha gerencia
pública para eso y se requiere mucha
plata para implementarlas y no tenemos
ni la plata ni los buenos gerentes para
llegar a feliz puerto
daniela su opinión sobre este plan
ambicioso 25 yo creo que no es tan
ambicioso en la medida en que busca
realmente poner en marcha muchos de sus
puntos del acuerdo de paz que se
quedaron en veremos por ejemplo la
jurisdicción agraria que ha sido como
uno de sus puntos en cómo resolvemos los
problemas es sobre la tierra el tema por
ejemplo enfoque de drogas a pesar de que
se ha hablado mucho por ejemplo de no
criminalizar tanto a los cultivadores
dar un tratamiento diferenciado como qué
hacemos con el tema de salud pública eso
tampoco se ha puesto en marcha o sea
creo que es de acuerdo con rodrigo en
que muchas de esas ideas son ideas
recicladas pero son ideas que nunca se
han puesto realmente en marcha ha habido
una voluntad política para ponerlas sean
caras o no sean caras porque pues
imagínate que cada vez que el estado
quiere implementar algo las respuestas
que no tenemos cómo pagarlo pues de
algún lado tenemos que mirar cómo
hacemos creo que por ejemplo haber
puesto un ministro como iván velásquez
al frente de defensa oa crear unos retos
porque hay unos temas ahí no solo de la
doctrina militar sino de que está
pasando por ejemplo con la corrupción
dentro de las fuerzas armadas que va por
lo menos alguien a interesarse en ese
tema y esos son un enfoque totalmente
novedoso de cómo se ha tratado
usualmente la política de defensa y
seguridad nacional en colombia tratar de
sacar la policía por ejemplo el
ministerio nuevo porque es que la
policía tiene una gran yo creo que una
gran contradicción en colombia es que se
ocupa al mismo tiempo de los
narcotraficantes y la seguridad
ciudadana y por eso uno ve unos una
absoluta abuso de la fuerza en temas
como la protesta social y al tiempo pues
ve a los por a las policías
desprotegidos frente a los bandidos del
plan del golfo en en territorios como el
bajo cauca antioqueño entonces creo que
si bien hay muchas de esas ideas
muchos expertos pasos logos han venido
repitiendo estos años realmente hay que
mirar que tantas veces se ha puesto
suficiente empeño a poner en práctica
algunas de ellas para decir que en
efecto o no en un fracaso daniela uno de
los puntos que llama la atención por lo
menos desde fuera de colombia es esa
posibilidad de dialogar con otros grupos
armados que ya hemos visto que se han
ampliado a lo largo de los últimos años
puntualmente la guerrilla de ln que
sigue completamente activa en cómo están
parados estos grupos vimos hace pocos
meses un gran paro armado en una zona de
colombia y paralizando incluso hasta una
capital departamental
y el gobierno diciendo que el clan del
golfo ya no existía como están
verdaderamente parados estos grupos como
ésta lln y qué tan factible es esa
negociación bueno fundamentalmente hoy
en colombia tenemos cuatro grupos
armados legales muy fuertes el primero
es el l n el segundo es el clan del
golfo y las dos disidencias de las farc
la segunda marquetalia y la que lideraba
gentil duarte que fue asesinado hace
unas semanas
ln ha tenido un gran fortalecimiento en
la zona del arauca y en la zona
fronteriza y siempre ha sido una zona en
la que ellos han influenciado y aparte
pues en el txoko donde actúa al frente
de guerra occidental por otro lado el
clan del golfo por supuesto tiene
pues nació un poco de las
desmovilizaciones paramilitares y sigue
teniendo una zona influencia muy fuerte
en el bajo cauca antioqueño en el sur de
córdoba demostrando con ese paro armado
que no era cierto que la captura o
entrega de otoniel le ponía fin a este
grupo porque además tenemos una una cosa
muy particular de estos nuevos grupos y
es que como son grupos armados que
tienen un recambio de de personas que
están dentro de ellos es tan rápido
matar a los cabecillas no significa
necesariamente debilitar los yo por
ejemplo ahorita y todo un tema con la
gente y huarte por qué pues mataron
alias jhonier mataron al que estaba de
segundo al mando y gentil duarte pues
también no sabemos por en ese momento en
la segunda marquetalia cuál es el estado
salud de iván márquez pero buena parte
de lo que era la cúpula de las farc que
armaron ese grupo están pues muertos de
romañá el paisa pero los grupos siguen a
caídos entonces ahí tiene que haber un
enfoque de cómo tramitar estos grupos y
los en estos cuatro años cada uno de sus
cuatro grupos así que duplicó el número
de hombres según nuestros propios
informes activos
rodrigo le preguntó por la parte
internacional desde fuera de colombia
también han criticado al país algunos de
los países que han colaborado con el
acuerdo de paz noruega la unión europea
y ya se muestran un poco desconfiados
con seguir apostándole o donando dando
fondos para este tipo de acuerdos como
ver esta posibilidad de llevar a cabo
este acuerdo de paz que ya viene en
marcha lo que plantea el presidente
electo gustavo petro de cara a
vendérselo a la comunidad internacional
para poderlo financiar porque ya sabemos
que internamente pues las cosas no es
tan fácil y dada la coyuntura
internacional va a haber plata para eso
no lograba haber mantenido la tesis en
este mismo programa aquí no hay plata y
no hay plata porque desde el gobierno
del doctor santo se raspó la olla y
después se terminó ere que te respete
raspar por cuenta la pandemia en el
gobierno lo que no hay plata recordemos
dos cosas la primera una muy fuerte
crítica que los negociadores del ex
grupo terrorista de las farc
elevaron una vez se firmó el acuerdo y
es que ellos querían y me parece que era
muy sensato y muy reflexivo y muy lógico
poner unos anexos en donde a manera de
excel se valorizarán y se pusieran las
cuentas claras de cuánto costaba la
implementación y el gobierno del doctor
santos impidió eso porque se sabía de
antemano que era impagable y lo segundo
se ha venido tratando de la idea casi
que idílica y un poco ingenua si se me
permite la expresión de sostener que la
paz en colombia' los más de 140 billones
de pesos que cuesta la implementación
del acuerdo del doctor santos con las
va a ser subsidiada pagada o sufragada
por la comunidad internacional lo que
dice la experiencia internacional sobre
todo la experiencia centroamericana es
que no llega al 8% la ayuda
internacional frente al total al
universo de costos es no está la
implementación del acuerdo de modo que
usted anota un tema muy sensible todo
puede ser muy bonito todo puede ser
absolutamente bello desde el punto de
vista de la teoría y el del papel al
cual le cabe todo pero a la hora de la
implementación hay que ser bastante
serios y de alguna manera coherente
llevar algo en la comunidad rodrigo
entonces esto se va a convertir este
acuerdo de paz y la implementación una
especie como el plan colombia que se
volvió un pozo sin fondo donde eeuu daba
plata para la ayuda militar a colombia y
bueno vemos el escenario en el que
estamos años de inversión en las fuerzas
militares no el estado no ganó
militarmente el conflicto sigue esto va
a ser otro pozo sin fondo plata que
llega para la corrupción en colombia
con el debido respeto me da pena
contradecir su punto de vista yo creo
que el estado colombiano y gracias entre
otras cosas a la gestión pastrana uribe
y el plan colombia auspiciado
fundamentalmente por el gobierno de los
estados unidos ganó militarmente pero la
guerra irregular la guerra de guerrillas
la guerra contra el crimen terrorista se
pierde
políticamente y lo que pasó es que como
sociedad perdimos es decir el estado
nacional manifestó su voluntad de
encontrar en la cultura del diálogo la
vía correcta para defender el estado de
derecho y creo que ya los resultados
están demostrando que por ahí no es la
cosa tampoco es echar bala y estrés sin
eso por ahí tampoco en la cosa pero
definitivamente arrodillar a una nación
frente a 52 mil terroristas no eran la
mejor forma de negociar entonces
evidentemente le le le contradijo con el
debido respeto y me perdonará a todos
permitido no el programa y en público
primero colombia siga ganando
militarmente las fuerzas militares
398 gracias al franco lo estaban
arrojando exitosísimos resultados
ejemplo rodrigo se me acaba el tiempo
perdón debo debo cortarlo debo
interrumpirlo porque te hace marca el
tiempo de dar paso al informativo les
agradezco se que se nos quedan
muchísimos temas sobre la mesa y por
debatir pero por lo menos hacemos una
mirada un panorama de cómo está la
situación y cuál es el futuro que va a
tener la paz en este país suramericano a
danielle aquí en el estudio a rodrigo en
conexión remota les agradezco por haber
estado con nosotros ustedes pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios a través
de las redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]